tout autre sujet euro 2016 à présent
l'équipe d'irlande qui avait pour camp
de base versailles est rentrée chez elle
ce lundi après sa défaite contre
l'équipe de france en 8e de finale après
avoir été mené 1 à 0 les bleus ont su
rebondir pour l'emporter 2 1 en deuxième
période grâce à un doublé d'antoine
griezmann match évidemment été très
suivie dans les yvelines dans le barreau
paris à versailles
une centaine de supporters maquillés et
déguisés aux couleurs de la france s'est
réunie pour regarder la rencontre dans
ce pub irlandais les fans nous donnent
leurs pronostics pour les prochains
matches de l'équipe de france on les
écoute 1 j'espère oui j'espère qu'après
les landes j'espère qu'on va gagner ça
nous ferait du bien au moral à tous mais
j'espère que si on se rencontre
l'allemagne bon on va se faire manger
comme d'hab comme devant finalement d
habitude autre chose ouais plutôt ça
passe maintenant mais pas plus j'ai
jamais sur un malentendu ça peut au
pessimisme
ça peut passer